I'm not mad at grown adults living with
their parents for a period of time if
there is a life transition that is
happening you've moved to the city where
they are and you want to live there for
a bit there are reasons and again great
reasons for adult children to move back
home for a period of time right and not
for this nebulous oh I'm just saving
money on rent I'm going to just keep
going yeah no no no for a period of time
with an end date very specific all of it
because there is such power when you're
a young adult when you're 22 23 and
you're having to figure out the world
there's just date I mean there's
something in that dignity there's this
idea that I have to Now problem solve
and I can't just you know fall back on
my parents and those lessons and skills
that you learn through problem solving
are what you lean on when you're 30 and
40 and 50 and through the rest of your
life